you're looking at the beautiful augusta
national golf club home of the masters
where this year's tournament is
officially underway this morning
[Music]
a short time ago gary player and jack
nicholas teed off at the honorary
starter ceremony joined for the first
time by tom watson
the three champions have a combined 11
green jackets in a few hours all eyes
will be on five time champion tiger
woods he plans his return to tournament
golf just 14 months after he was badly
injured in a car crash cbs sports will
broadcast the masters for the 67th
consecutive year and the great jim nance
of cbs sports will be covering the
masters for the 37th year in a row he
joins us from augusta national jim good
morning my friend how are you doing good
morning good morning friends it's great
to get this all underway it was a
special ceremony just minutes ago we're
in a 30-minute delay because of heavy
rains getting the course prepared and
yes the masters is officially
let's start with tiger woods less than
14 months ago he had this car accident
we remind everybody that he could have
lost his leg it was a car crash he could
have lost his life did you think that
you would see tiger woods back in
tournament play
i did not
i was just with tiger a few weeks ago
down
in jupiter florida where he lives and we
taped a documentary that will air this
sunday on cbs at one o'clock the 25 year
anniversary of his win for the ages and
i got no real indication at all spending
a good portion of the day with tiger
that he'd be ready this soon he did say
he would be playing at some point this
year but
i didn't expect it to be this quickly so
no one works harder i mean it's just
amazing to see the determination that's
still there at 46. and uh i think i
think he's going to play well
we saw his practice round we're looking
at clips of him hitting the ball but
when you were with him you can assess a
athlete's body how did he look how was
he walking around does he look like he's
physically ready for this
well physically i mean he works out like
no one else uh the day i saw him he
began his day at six o'clock with a four
hour workout and i said how did it go
this morning goes um same as it is every
day i hate it i hate every minute of it
but he puts in that work it and
he doesn't let the fact that it's hard
and it's not enjoyable getting away from
the goal and that is to compete and
still try to compete for major
championships but there is a little bit
of a hitch in his uh gate
that would be expected you documented it
nate i mean it was february 23rd a year
ago
and i had just conducted an interview
with him in the tower at riviera in los
angeles
a day and a half before that and and
next thing you know like you said it
could have lost his leg but he truly
could have lost his life it was a
horrific accident one car accident
that
i don't know how he survived it to be
honest but here he is back again he
hasn't competed in a real tournament
he's played in the father-son event with
charlie
his son but he hasn't played in a real
tournament since we had the masters
tournament in the fall of 2020. in
november of 2020 is the last time he put
the t in the ground and competed for
real until today
hey jim you mentioned that hitch in
tigers gate so the the course there in
augusta i think is about more than 7 000
yards if you're a golf ball if you're a
human being walking the whole thing uh
talk to us about the rigors just of that
process
well that i think is his biggest concern
his swing is fine although we'll have to
see when he gets some side hill lies and
has to push off that right leg because
you fire off of that side
and that's going to be demanding now
here here's the thing he came here last
week and got everybody stirred because
he flew into augusta for a practice
round he wanted to see what the recovery
was like for him after that now remember
he's been playing nine whole practice
rounds this week but he's got to play
today tomorrow if he makes the cut
saturday sunday so it builds it gets
gradually more difficult for him and
here's the x factor it's it's wet here
we had three and a half hour three and a
half inches of rain over the last two
days it's soggy we call it being
heavy-legged when you play in conditions
like this and uh that's gonna make it a
little bit more difficult still
this guy just has a way of performing
and i think he's gonna do a lot better
than people think he has one benefit and
that is there are zero expectations for
him to do well
so he comes in here
with us
just in awe of seeing him play again no
one expects him to contend so
from that standpoint mentally i think
it's a good thing i think he's got a
freebie so to speak because the
expectations are so low now don't fool
yourself his expectations are to win
this thing that's all he cares about
he's here to win that's it i hadn't
thought of i haven't thought of it that
way the expectations but i'll bet he has
a lot of self-imposed pressure because
he wants to pull this off but i'm also
curious about other players because i
think everybody's excited to see tiger
including i would think his com his his
competitors but who are the other names
that are going hey fellas you know i'm
here too playing who are those people
that we should also be looking at that's
a good question gayle i will say this i
don't think any of the other players are
saying hey look at me give me some
attention they love the fact that this
tournament as of
monday when he said i think i can play
has been completely about tiger so for
those who are expected to do well they
too benefit by this psychologically
justin thomas john rahm
dustin johnson brooks koepka jordan
spieth and don't forget rory mcilroy who
has now his eighth attempt to complete
the career slam grand slam and golf and
i think he's someone to watch i really
do and he's coming in again not
shouldering the burden of all these
expectations that everybody's going to
heap on him it's all about tigers so
these guys like the fact they're coming
in kind of under the radar to play this
tournament if it's not tiger jim do you
have any predictions on who you think
will be wearing that green jacket on
sunday i was afraid you're going to put
me on the limb i'll go i'm always a
story guy i like what the best story is
we've got a young man named scottie
scheffler who's won three times in the
last six weeks
he's going to be dangerous but i you
know the story of mcilroy trying to
complete the career grand slam um there
have only been six who have ever done it
and and uh
rory this is the one missing piece and i
i would i would love to see rory be the
next guy to win all four legs of of the
major championships
and i know roy would be looking forward
to putting on that green jacket for the
first time right right here that's where
we do it yeah this is this is the
ceremony spot right here
before we let you go i have to ask you
about um how you get this all done you
have been called the busiest person in
all of tv so you go from the final four
to the championship game and now the
masters in the span of seven days how do
you just get your rest between monday
night's championship game and this
morning and this appearance right here
i'm fine i am renewed i'm thrilled to be
here it's the 37th year in a row i've
gone from the ncaa championship game
right into augusta i call it a tradition
unlike any other yes jim nance give
yourself a round of applause
thank you guys all right thank you so
much hi now here's the rundown of all of
the master's action here on cbs today
and tomorrow we'll bring you the
highlights at 11 35 pm third round
coverage begins saturday at 3 p.m
eastern noon pacific and the final round
coverage starts sunday at 2 p.m eastern
11 a.m pacific here on cbs end on our
streaming service paramount plus